كيم جونغ يصدر قانونا جديدا،
ألغى الاحتفال بعيد الأم،
ومنع المسيحيين من التقرب للمسيح،
وأمرهم بعبادةوجدته؟
نعم كيم جونغ يجعل من جدته إله للكوريين،
ما هذا الجنون؟
هل أصبحت قرارات كيم جونغ شيئا طبيعي؟
وهل يحق للرئيس التحكم بمعتقدات مواطنيه؟
وإذا كنت جدته إله فماذا سيصبح هو؟
يا للسخرية!..
الرئيس الكوري الشمالي كيم جونغ اون يظهر مجددا بقرار غريب،
ويمنع شعبه من الاحتفال، بعيد الأم،
الذي يحتفل به العالم أجمع، بمختلف دياناتهم،
لماذا يا ترى؟
،، رأى كيم جونغ أن الشعب الكوري الشمالي،
سينشغل عن الاهتمام برئيسه، خلال هذا اليوم،
ولابد للشعب أن لا يغفل عن الاهتمام بكيم جونغ
وإلاااااا.. .. الجوب معروف مسبقا....
هل وصل شعب كوريا الشمالية لأسوأ مرحلة يعيشها؟
في الحقيقة فإن المتابعين يرددون أن كوريا الشمالية لم تصل بعد
إلى أسوأ مراحلها في المعيشة خلال حكم كيم جونغ،
فالأسوأ سيأتي به المستقبل،
هذا الرئيس الذي قد يعدم- الفرد أو الجماعة، وقد يعدم أقاربه وأبناءه-
لأصغر الأسباب كالتقصير في أداء الوظيفة مثلا،،
لكن الجديد هذه المرة هو منع الاحتفال بعيد الأم،
ولم يكتفي بذلك ولن يكتفي،
فقد طالب زعيم كوريا_الشمالية شعبه بالاحتفال بمولد جدته
التي ولدت عشية رأس السنة الميلادية
والتي جعل شعبها يدعونها بـ"الأم المقدسة للثورة"،
هذه الجدة التي ماتت في ظروف غامضة عام1949.
وقالت صحيفة "إنديا تايمز" أن كيم يونغ أون، دعا شعبه إلى نسيان المسيح وعبادة جدّته.
هذه الجدة ، كانت ناشطة شيوعية،
وانخرطت في موظفي العصابات التي تقاتل ضد اليابان،
ماجعلها قديسة لهم وقد أعلن كيم جونغ يوم ميلاد جدته أجازة رسمية للشعب الكوري...
وفي عام 2014، هدد كيم يونغ أون جارته كوريا الجنوبية بحرب طاحنة،
عندما علم بأن كوريا الجنوبية ستضع شجرة عيد الميلاد على الحدود،
وبهذا التهديد تراجعت الجارة عن احتفالها خوفا من كيم جونغ،،،
وفي مناسبة عيد الأم في كوريا الشمالية،
يزور مئات الآلاف مقبرة الجدة في بيونغ_يانغ
ويقومون بتقديم باقة من زهور الأقحوان، يقومون بشرائها من متجر بالقرب من المقبرة ...
وتنظم رحلات لزيارة قبر الجدة، من قبل الجنود والطلاب
،وتعتبر هي الأم الأولى في البلاد.
مع كيم جونغ، لن يصدر قانون جديد إلا وكان موضوعا دسما لوسائل الإعلام،
فهذا الزعيم الكوري يلقب بالمجنون،
والمجنون لا يأتي بقونين طبيعية،..
فماذا تتوقعون أنتم مشاهدونا ماذا لو دار بكم الزمن
وذهبتم إلى كوريا الشمالية ومرت بكم هذه المناسبة هل ستحتفلون بها؟
فضلا وليس أمرا، اضغط على زر الإعجاب وفعل الاشتراك في القناة،
واضغط على جرس التنبيهات، ليصل كل جديد على قناة شاهد لتعرف